this is it
a microbiologist mm um and I you know
coming into a cave any cave for that
matter it is not in my nature but the
drive that Lily get me into different
kind of cave would be the drive of
trying to find the answers my quest in
science it has been a continuous
research project trying to find new
antibiotics and I chose to look into
caves
there's a quiet crisis going on in
hospitals around the world right now
certain strains of bacteria no longer
respond to any known antibiotics there's
a word for these antibiotic resistant
bacteria
we call them superbugs and unless we can
develop new antibiotics superbugs could
make a lot of people very very sick we
are racing against the clock in a way
because you already see a number of
people who actually just has a
meaningless death just because of they
had this minor infection it is
imperative for us to look into new drugs
a new source of what could be the
habitats for new drugs
there are lots of steps that involved
him in this kind of research first off
you need to go find the appropriate cave
to go into the cave collect samples what
dr. chiefdom is looking for in this cave
is in fact bacteria not the infectious
bacteria that makes us sick but benign
bacteria that can produce antibiotic
compounds this is how many of the
antibiotics we have today were first
developed in this isolated cave she's
hoping to find new species of these
bacteria that no scientist has ever seen
before
basically it could be anywhere in soda
straw lollipops and cauliflowers all of
this could be a microhabitats that such
unique microorganisms could live in you
want honest I learned to love it I just
can't let my imagination go to different
places I think it's it's awesome you get
the sample back to the lab and then you
will try to isolate as many as bacteria
you can do you want to take a look at
that the other soda straw sure yeah
let's do that
look like more promising this side it is
a painstaking process can we say a
finding a needle in a haystack
yeah maybe six haystacks
dr. cheap them and her students extract
the most promising bacteria from their
cave samples and try to grow them to
greater numbers on lab plates these are
our cave bacteria grown from the iron
curtain cave you can see that there are
different populations community of
bacteria is growing then the real test a
sample of the cave bacteria is placed on
a dish apna coli an empty gap around the
cave bacteria indicates antibiotic
activity a successful find dr. cheap
Thome has been doing this for a long
time and she's found many bacteria in
caves that can kill a coli the hard part
is what comes next actually developing a
life-saving drug that can take up to 25
years it's hard because I have been
already doing this for 14 years last
year we came closer to a chemical
structure but turnout activity is very
unstable
we lost activity of the after compounds
that we isolated from bacteria so then
now we come back to a drawing board
I'm still human being I I am still
easily disappointed but I got myself
away from those kind of negative
thoughts because I would remind myself
that it doesn't come easy nothing comes
easy and I think the reward at the end
would be well worth it
I would like to see that the best cast
scenario for me would be I would be a
part of finding a new drugs a new
antibiotics to help save people life